declare that KIA Mather is duly elected
Labor's newest Member of Parliament was
seven years old when his party last won
a British general election we have
Rewritten the rules on where labor can
win 25 year old Kia Maha overturned a
conservative majority of more than 20
000 in a by-election in the north of
England his party hopes this is a taste
of what's to come you voted for change
you put your trust in the labor party
and we hear you we hear that cry for
change away from the chaos away from
those Rising bills the crumbling public
services that Sarah Joanne Dyke has been
duly elected the conservatives lost two
of three seats in by-elections on
Thursday the governing party held on
just to the Uxbridge seat of former
prime minister Boris Johnson he resigned
after he was founder of misled
Parliament over parties in his residence
during the pandemic lockdowns
Investments has been acting like the
next election is the done deal the labor
party has been acting like it's a done
deal the people of Uxbridge just told
all of them that it's not
but his party only one here because of
local anger at the extension of a scheme
from Labor's London mayor that imposes
heavy fees on people using older more
polluting cars Nationwide labor leads
the conservatives by more than 20
percent in the latest polling so already
you can hear and smell the nerves of the
Tory back benches now exploding into a
more full-blown Terror as they realize
that their job prospects are truly
endangered you can know that at any time
piano that has a majority of about 15
000 is basically toast unless things
dramatically change
strikes overpay High inflation Rising
mortgage rates are all fueling voter
frustration with the government
I just I think they get wiped out what
they've done to labor last time will
turn red I think people want change
don't they and they don't think it's
going downhill at the moment Rishi sunak
has perhaps about 12 months to turn his
party's fortunes around the speculation
there'll be a general election by
November next year but it's going to be
an uphill battle the conservative party
has been in power for 13 years and is
struggling to point to any achievements
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Uxbridge